some moving videos shared by Southern
Hills Hospital they were taking care of
18 year old Jordan brister until he
passed away before Jordan's organs were
donated an honor walk was held to
commemorate that selfless choice
when we have individuals show up to
honor the patient as a transporter from
the hospital room down to the Lor for
the surgery the hallway has people kind
of lined up through and then the event
is rolled between these people just
having that much support that I've just
never seen on such short notice also
only to show what kind of people they
are and what kind of you know individual
he was
and overflow of love and support for
Jordan's family shown there through what
is a very difficult time
and Brian there is a crucial need for
organ donors all across the country
currently more than a hundred thousand
people are waiting for life-saving
transplants including 600 nevadans every
donor can save up to eight lives and
also enhance dozens more the organs that
are most in need kidneys liver and heart